I'm Ramsay personality George Campbell
joined this hour by Ken Coleman and
special guest Rachel Cruz it is so good
to have you guys good day when we get
Rachel in here with us whole sports day
all three of us it is like sports it's
Sports Center I found out about 10
minutes ago and I couldn't be happier I
mean the only thing missing here are the
cocktails that we see at smart money
happy hour across the desk
it could have been a party it's not
happening well there's a good reason
Rachel's here why is she here George
Well a big news hit just a few moments
ago student loan forgiveness is not
happening it is official now the Supreme
Court officially struck down Biden
student loan debt relief plan that would
have forgiven up to 20 grand for federal
student loan borrowers and Rachel and I
put an Instagram story out just kind of
sharing the news giving people some next
steps in a meeting uh and you know then
the texts were coming in that the
Supreme Court had ruled this and it was
like oh my gosh because we've been
talking about this for 18 months it
feels like seven years from the moment
it was announced a long time and if
you've been listening to the show you
know that we've our number one thing for
you guys is that we want you debt free
we want you out of debt so we're like
listen if this passes and you take
advantage of it go that's great if you
have a moral conviction against it then
don't but it's not passed yet don't wait
on someone else you know to make
decisions AKA Washington to fix your
life so continue to pay it on because
there was no interest right now there's
a pause on interest you could be paying
down the principle all this right so
this is in our head so George and I
I'm like George oh my gosh they shut it
down like it's not happening let's jump
on the social because that's where
people are to you know just give the
announcement talk about it
apparently we are too happy about it is
and so then we had to do another video
to be like y'all it's not that we're
like wanting people to to suffer we just
always knew this was the case so all
that to say there is uh a lot of emotion
around this which we understand because
also you guys we hate student loans we
hate this whole industry it is predatory
people these 18 year olds sign sign
their lives away and they had no clue
what they're doing the people the adults
in their lives whether ignorant or
believe something else Usher them into
this like the whole thing is frustrating
so we are against this whole industry so
we're not for it so we want you out of
it
um but we also know that you're the one
that's gonna have to change your life
and in sitting and waiting around on any
program or any one person to do that
you're not going to get the change that
you want
great great way to put that Rachel the
big thing for us is we're not glad
because people aren't getting help we're
glad that the will they won't they game
is over and that you're not being lied
to anymore and that you don't have this
false hope and that you're in control
now you can actually do something about
this instead of waiting on a politician
and Ken you were on Fox news earlier
today talking about this very issue yeah
and I think you just hit on the real
problem with this understandably
whether you agree with us on debt and
loans and you're just kind of checking
the show out or you saw their post and
you were offended uh let me just say
that I'm angry for you because if you
believed and a lot of you did millions
of you believed that this was possible
that's not fair to you this is an
emotionally charged issue because on the
other side of it as I mentioned on Fox
News today there were millions of
Americans I'm one of them who did take
out student loans and did pay them off
my wife too who is a masters in
broadcasting and so this was an
emotionally charged issue from the
get-go from all sides from all sides and
I think it's important to point that out
and and I I appreciate you guys saying
this I'll be honest with you it bothers
me that you guys and the reason you feel
the need to address is because you're
both really nice sweet people I'll be
honest nicer and sweeter than me because
the reality is is that what we have said
for 18 months or however long it was is
that folks we didn't think this was
gonna ever take place because of the
constitutionality of it we didn't file
the lawsuit multiple states did you had
private student loan firms that were
going to file lawsuits so here's where
we stand we can help you get rid of this
debt but you sign signed up for this
you did yeah and so there's a
responsibility into Rachel's point
I know it's bone crushing today and I
guess my point is is I I want to throw
some empathy out to say we get it
because you are struggling
and it hurts today and come August
there's going to be a lot of people
hurting when these loan payments start
back up so here's the point we want to
make to you
we believe in you we have a process
called the baby steps that have worked
for millions of Americans and regardless
of who's President and who's in Congress
and who's in charge we don't want you to
fall for this stuff anymore we want you
to get serious about getting free from
debt and that's what I want to encourage
those people that are hurting today yes
and I hate that begs to the point too
you guys that there's like paying for a
system even like debt consolidation like
all these like things in the financial
industry that feel like shortcuts
it's always going to backfire like
there's a point that like things are
gonna by far and y'all were saying
earlier um it may have been you George
in our meeting as we're talking about
this that that actually people during
this waiting period of 18 months student
loan they were getting money back now
that they're going to have to pay again
yes they're gonna have to pay back it's
like that's correct student loan
companies were saying hey we'll refund
you now we'll refund you here's your 10
grand back we're going to reinstate your
loan balance and good luck with the
government for giving this that's a
punch in the guts now those people like
it's just like it's all of that stuff
you guys so it's so entangled and as we
sit on this side of the desk trying to
help give hope and empowerment to people
when we see this this narrative play and
again regardless of party like
Republicans do this Democrat like it's
we see this stuff and it's so and it's
so hard because we also know as we sit
on the said desk that we have people
that stand on the debt free the debt
free stage that do debt-free screams
they've worked hard they've sacrificed
and they've done it so we know that you
can do this and so the fact that we're
not going to be talking about this
anymore in that sense of like this
waiting game I'm gonna wait and see it
no now you can put action to your life
and that's what we're excited about yeah
I can't tell you how many calls we've
taken in the last year or two just
people going should I do this because
what if they forgive it and I'm going
you're putting your life on hold and
putting your faith in a politician when
in history has that ever been a good
idea yeah and George I remember when
they first even announced this 18 months
ago I think we were on the air because
it was a day or two after we had people
a friend but like that we both know
kind of could get mad at us they're like
why would you tell people to keep paying
on their student loans like they were
because we're like because it's probably
not going to happen they're like are you
kidding isn't it like it was a
disagreement there and we're just like
oh my gosh no keep paying because
there's no interest right now and you
could be putting down the principal like
it just mathematically makes sense so um
that we are here for you for those of
you that are wanting to move forward in
your education and you think the only
way is student loan debt I can promise
you it's not we're here for you on that
yeah some of you are going wait a second
what do I do I don't want to get stuck
in this deal and so that's the point we
want to make today is that no matter
what you're feeling on either side of
this
um you can live life debt free that's
all we're trying to tell you give us a
chance to walk you and talk you through
it that's what we want people here today
because I can't point out enough how
many people are devastated emotionally
today devastated over this decision
but now it's what are we going to do
next because we can only wallow for so
long and so your payments are restarting
in October interest starts in September
we've got to make a plan we've got to
get on a budget we've got to pay this
debt off and we are here to help you
because we believe you are the hero not
the government yes that's how it's been
for 30 years and that is not changing
and uh you know I'll run on that
campaign promise Ken I'll vote for you
thank you somebody's giving me a ballot
I'll write your name in thanks for
hanging out Rachel thank you guys for
having me thanks Rachel this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
this hour it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
what we just shared all about the
student loan forgiveness not happening
the Supreme Court ruling that struck
down Biden's plan and I want to let you
all know listening out there that our
team is keeping up with this stuff and
we have an amazing guide to getting rid
of your student loans keeping you up to
date on what's Happening and if you go
to ramseysolutions.com student loans you
can get all of the info there and I'll
make sure our team puts all of the
information in the show notes the
description wherever you're listening or
watching you'll be able to go down there
and click on that link and get the
resources you need because we want to
see you get rid of these loans now that
it's up to you and here's the thing we
believe in you we believe that you have
the power to get rid of these loans
yourself without the help of the
government or politicians I know it's a
hot take Ken in today's world but we've
believed in you guys for 30 years this
whole show
is about you believing that you're the
secret sauce to your success that's it
it's that simple and so you can go check
out that resource ramseysolutions.com
student loans let's get to the phones
they are lighting up we've got Peter in
Minneapolis coming up Peter what's going
on
Pete are you with us I am I'm here hey
how can we help
I have
um I want to know if I should fill my
Tesla stock and pay off my mortgage whoa
oh boy that's a good problem to have
this is like a double whammy for you
it's a mortgage question and a Tesla
question there's so much going on yeah
uh did you just purchase this Tesla
stock outright on your own
I did not I work for Tesla for the last
four and a half years which means you
got a killer deal on these stocks
I did half of it is
um Merit like signing bonuses and raises
half of it I've purchased through the
employee uh yeah CP yeah
okay
um
how much do you have in there and I was
just
uh well today it's at 207. depends on
what Elon tweets out next right right it
could go up or down depending on the
Tweet okay that's awesome and what's
your mortgage
198 left oh my gosh dude can you imagine
if you just went down to the bank and
just wire transferred that thing and you
were done with it today
um I need to figure out what I'm gonna
pay on taxes I have like a ballpark on
the capital gains be ready for that
right yeah and so if you do you have
money in the bank as well outside of
that yeah we have
um 25 000 in our emergency fund
okay um and we're debt-free besides the
house dude you guys are crushing it how
old are you
41. wow what's your mortgage payment
uh 950 bucks we did a 30-year
um but we've been paying it off we've
been doing like 1600 a month
knocking that thing down yeah we have a
we have another house that's paid for
our first house
um well I met my wife we went through
Dave Ramsey we got married we paid her
townhouse off
we had a kid she stopped working to be a
stay-at-home mom and then about two and
a half years ago we bought this house
um
so we have some so we've already baby
step seven and then we bought it by our
house and now we're working our way out
of that that mortgage very cool well I'm
proud of you guys have done really
really well and I'll tell you what I
would do and I've done this in a sense
not to pay off my mortgage but I had
some Apple stock from when I worked
there and when I was getting out of debt
I cashed that thing out and I paid off I
used it to to finish off my debt free
journey and I have zero regrets and
here's what you're gonna do you're gonna
go oh my gosh if I had held on to that
Tesla stock it could have been 10 more
than it was and my buddies are all
making fun of me guess what dude you
don't have any payments
yeah and so if Tesla starts laying
people off you go all right I'll go find
I'm not worried I don't I don't got
bills to pay and so that's the kind of
financial piece I'm talking about and it
is so worth it to liquidate those
non-retirement assets to get there of
course you're doing it the smart way
look into the capital gains and make
sure you have the money to pay that as
well but I'm becoming debt-free house
and everything I like George's advice
Peter because I'm sure you've heard that
uh it appears that uh Elon is gonna
wrestle or get in a cage match with Mark
Zuckerberg or Facebook have you ever
heard about news Ken do you not pay
attention to this do you not know this
this is big news there's so much Elon
news I can't even keep up anymore no
this is absolutely a thing I mean Elon
has said I'm gonna now Zuckerberg okay
it trains in the Mixed Martial Arts Elon
is basically a smart marshmallow and so
this is dangerous so I'm getting rid of
this stock Beyond George's advice I
think Zuckerberg the battle of the
billionaires I think Zuckerberg puts him
in a pretzel it could be dicey and so
I'm I'm selling the stock for a
completely different reason that's not a
reason I would have guest but it's it's
a good from the headlines George that's
incredible well Peter we're proud of you
man we are cheering you on and I hope
you call back and maybe do your debt
free scream or come visit us in
Nashville and send me some Tesla swag
that'd be fun
as well do you have no dignity no idea
you're begging for Tesla gear nah that
wasn't a bag it was a it was a friend
asking a friend I don't think so I don't
think you guys know each other we're not
on those terms no I don't think so but
I'm I'm proud of them that's inspiring
that is great he's done really
absolutely sell the stock okay let's
move on to I said Kaylee uh Cali there
we go Cali is in Michigan Callie welcome
to the show
hey
um long time listener uh I just want to
start off with uh word debt free besides
our house
um but I'm I currently am like an X-ray
tech by trade
um so I worked all through the pandemic
everything was great I moved to a new
job in 21 I'm actually an Interventional
Radiology technologist now so it's a
very kind of condensed field from x-ray
um I love where I work I love what I do
I love all my doctors my nurses that I
work with my co-workers everything's
great but we've known about a two people
leaving us basically for six months and
management refused to do anything to try
to get us extra help so when I signed on
it was I would you know work four days a
week and then I would take seven days a
call for a 28 day pay period because
there was four of us well now I'm
working 10 hour days five days a week
and taking 14 days of call all of a 28
day pay period and they refused to pay
us more and they refused to give us any
kind of benefit for doing this other
than congratulations you're making more
money because you're making overtime and
whatever so this happened in early May
and I said by the time it hits my
birthday which is tomorrow oh I'm still
frustrated I was gonna call you guys
okay so so what's the question so I
could make more money elsewhere and
closer to home
um like I said it's a really small
community so everybody kind of knows
each other so I don't know if I should
take the leap and try to you know apply
for jobs closer to home that would make
more money or if I should stay where I
really enjoy it and just hoping that
they hire on more people soon later
have you had this conversation with
leadership to say what is the plan to
hire more help
yes what's the answer many conversations
and it's oh well the jobs are out there
they're posted and the problem is we
keep getting candidates but basically
the candidates are also X-ray techs that
want to go into the Interventional field
but they're not going to pay them enough
to do it they would actually be if they
hired in making more than me all right
so I've worked there for two years yeah
so Kelly we got about a minute and a
half so I want to get as much help too
as I can in that time I don't think you
enjoy this place anymore and I
understand what you meant when you said
I enjoy it but you really don't enjoy it
it has become a place of resentment for
you not because of the actual work but
because of the environment and then and
then the leadership and how you're
treated
and so that is only going to continue to
get worse you you can bite the stick and
you can get through it for a certain
amount of time and I think that certain
amount of time is to find something else
if you really love the work and you can
find that work somewhere else and make
more money I think it's a no-brainer
um I see no evidence based on what you
have told me that leadership is is in an
urgent uh state to try to relieve you
all they are just kind of going along
going along going along or they at least
should be communicating hey we know
you're frustrated
we know you're overworked hang in there
that's not there and so I think you
start looking
and if it gets better in the time that
you're looking great if it doesn't it's
time to move on because you're quickly
moving to a place of resentment and
that's not good for you mentally
physically or spiritually yeah when the
resentment shows up the seeds have been
sown you got to get going that's what I
say you can stitch that on a pillow at
TJ Maxx and sell it if you need I think
that's a Cracker Barrel right now
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
whether one
guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40 percent off everything site-wide go
to blinds.com for more information
foreign
[Music]
Ken Coleman this hour listen we have
people who tune into every episode of
the Ramsey show we have data that shows
that they know all the stuff we teach
about money they can sit behind this
desk and you could recite all of the
advice and yet they still feel stressed
out and stuck they're not where they
want to be financially how is that
possible well it's because knowing what
to do with your money isn't the problem
actually doing it is it's about Behavior
change and we always say personal
finance is 80 Behavior change it's only
20 head knowledge and The Proven way to
change your behavior is by taking
Financial Peace University this is the
class it's the difference between trying
to get in shape on your own versus
hiring a personal trainer because you
have a coordinator you have
accountability you have Community you're
forced to show up every week and go did
you watch the lesson did you do the
action steps did you make your budget
and that's what makes it so powerful and
twice worked for millions of people
and after nine weeks you will never
handle money the same way again that's
what happened to me back in 2013 when I
first went through it so don't just
listen to this show commit to doing what
it takes to win go join an FPU class
near you or online at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com FPU
Chris joins us up next in Fort Worth
Chris welcome to the show
honored to be with you George and Ken
how are you guys doing we are doing
great my man how can we help
much of my take-home pay should go to
more to my four walls ah that's an
exciting question so for those that are
listening four walls or food utilities
your shelter Transportation all of that
stuff and so you've got your budget set
out what's your income
this month is ten thousand wow
so this is this is partially why we
don't give recommended percentages for
every category because if we said hey
you should spend uh 15 of your income on
food whether you make a thousand dollars
a month or ten thousand dollars a month
right that would be wild
right for someone to spend 150 versus
1500 and so it's hard to get percentages
outside of the housing category uh which
we do have one for that which is no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay
including your if you you got a mortgage
or rent
uh we have a mortgage and it's really
low we're trying to knock that thing out
and it's just bugging us but outside the
mortgage uh our four walls are 33 of our
take-home pay this month that sounds
very reasonable I think a lot of America
is jealous right now and partially it's
because you guys have an amazing
take-home pay
it scares us to death I mean are you
does anything feel out of control to you
as far as utilities Transportation or
food costs in your budget what's kind of
the hardware it's a future projection
I'm looking at here we thought it would
be a great idea because we would we knew
we would be that pretty pretty quickly
to move and to put focus our wealth into
a house and so we kind of front loaded
that instead of the 401K
um so we're about to be in this you know
we're about to have a paid off house but
property taxes in Texas are awful and so
is insurance and that alone is 15 of our
take-home pay this month you know on a
12th of a year you know if you were to
cut it out every month and so we had a
sinking fund for that and that's 15 and
so I think Ken was talking about this on
another Show recently but he said that
he took a pay cut in his life for a
season as a calculated risk and so we're
doing that too
um so I'm fully self-employed as of a
few months ago and so it may not be a
season maybe like a year
uh but home prices in our area over the
past two years and we've been here two
years have skyrocketed and I'm worried
that 15 that goes to property tax and
insurance might end up being 20 25. and
I'm wondering at what point like are we
gonna have to think about moving in five
years
that kind of thing because of property
taxes
yeah no it's bad let's do it no it's two
and a half percent of our uh home value
and they're trying to say it's 800.
right but let's just run the numbers
okay so I get I get where your head is
going but let's just play the numbers
out
so when you look at the way we treat our
property taxes uh I don't know George if
I mean I don't know if you if you
espouse wrapping them into the mortgage
payment yes um as part of the 25 that's
exactly it's usually wrapped in with
escrow right unless you have a paid for
house in which case you're setting this
up on your own exactly so you do it on
your own that's what I thought so in
that situation you just got to look at
it and go all right uh let's just look
at the numbers now what is that monthly
number that allows us to save up for the
property taxes if you're pulling it out
of your line item is that what you're
doing you're putting it in the budget
you're going okay we have to save this
much each month so that when the
property taxes come due it's 1500 that's
1200 for property tax and uh 300 for
home insurance right but what do you
expect that to go up to if these bumps
happen so what would that go up to the
property tax
um I mean it's probably going to be uh
1300 a month still but if it keeps going
up at this rate at like five years like
it could end up you know being a whole
other grand
um but I just don't I mean I guess it's
kind of a fear-based question yeah
that's what that would mean yeah it's
not reasonable I think the people of
Texas will Revolt yeah it's not going to
have fun to do my friend it's not going
to happen at that rate you're not going
to be paying three thousand dollars in
property taxes in five years is that
what you're essentially saying
yeah no it's not gonna happen my friend
it's not gonna happen I'm I'm just
trying to snap you out of this
um it's it's fear and I get it but
that's not what's gonna happen you'll
see some incremental increases for sure
but to George's point if that happens
you're talking Revolt in Texas okay
um and and so those kind of property tax
increases at that level would just be I
I just don't see a scenario where that's
going to happen and I wouldn't make any
plans around that possibility it's not
gonna break you stay on the course and I
would also be investing 15 and if you're
following the plan you're investing 15
have you guys been doing that because
you said you're from yeah that's right
now we're in uh John deloney's uh class
that just ended awesome you're doing
fine
George you guys might need to go on
vacation or something yeah
have you celebrated at all
um I mean we bought a house two years
ago boy that sounds like a real party
come on
we won't do anything it's fun
hey we're having some fun with you but
that accountant and your amygdala need a
break you are scared to death over
something that you don't need to be
worried about you can absorb oh go
research this okay oh I'll tell you what
it is oh I always love this little
explanation the amygdala is the back of
your brain is called the lizard brain
you can research that and it's where the
fear uh mechanism in the brain resides
and and so when we are fearful it's
fight or flight and you're getting real
flighty you're getting real nervous
about those property taxes and the fact
of the matter is he's in great financial
shape yeah there's people that call us
that think that are in better shape than
you and they're super broke and so a lot
of this is fear-based I think we've got
a we maybe have a flat tire we may want
to go hey do we need to actually dial
back on this aggressive house payment
and enjoy some of it or give some of it
that usually you know when you're a
little more open-handed with it you just
breathe a little easier and you have a
little more joy and so if that's you
guys I'd encourage you to look at the
budget and go where can we have some fun
and if it ever does get out of control
and you're like we got to move away from
Texas we'll deal with that when when we
get there but right now it's all just
speculation
well thank you guys so much yeah
absolutely you're a good dude Chris I
recommend a massage
Ken does love a good massage though
that's a good one well I will share Ken
because I pulled these numbers up uh
from our website and this is all you
know from the Bureau of Labor Statistics
from the USDA for those that are
wondering am I out of control with my
budget in these four wall categories so
for food USDA says singles that are aged
19 to 50 spend 314 to 371 a month if
you're a couple 19 to 50 spend around
685 and a family of four spends around
9.71 for the Thrifty plan so this isn't
like balling out this is hey we're
getting food on the table we're not
going crazy
for housing of course we say 25 of your
take-home pay which includes your
homeowners insurance your property taxes
your prime your principal your interest
any HOA fees any PMI that all gets
wrapped in there and then utilities 37 a
month is average uh for natural gas 129
a month for electricity and 58 a month
for water and other public services that
sounds about right for the average
person of course people are yelling at
their screens right now gone I pay twice
as much I'm sorry I don't know what to
tell you and then Transportation
gasoline other fuels and oil 179 a month
other forms of transportation 38 a month
and then maintenance repairs about 81 a
month so that may be helpful to some of
you just to go to my way people
heartburn but you know there's things
that you live in a high cost of living
area it's going to cost more you live in
the middle of nowhere you might be
paying a whole lot less and so you know
those decisions and where you live it
all matters you drive a Tesla like
George you have no gas but you know what
the DMV charges the electric vehicle
owners an extra 100 bucks a year good
just because we're not paying the gas
still good about that so that feels
great good Ken we're all fair and square
all right this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey show if
you're a new listener to the show and
you want a deeper dive on all the stuff
we talk about on the show especially the
Ramsay baby steps you want that next
step for your financial Journey you can
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on
the get started button and we'll help
you figure out that next step for
exactly where you're at today that's
ramseysolutions.com and click on get
started Sarah joins us up next in San
Francisco Sarah welcome to the show
all right thanks what's going on uh all
right uh I'm at the beginning of baby
step two with 141 in all kinds of vets
um except mortgage uh last year I moved
to California from Texas for work and uh
it came with the cost of living raise
but with the much higher rent and all of
my minimum payments I'm still in the red
every month um so I'm doing extra jobs
to make the ends meet um but there is
nothing left to throw at babies up to
um so I'm feeling really burnt out in my
current industry which has been in for
about 15 years
um and I would like to go back to school
to become a nurse
um but I just can't figure out what the
first problem to solve is
um if it's the cost of living that's the
biggest problem or changing Industries
or
um just what the biggest thing to solve
first is I can't figure out how to break
the the jam and to get started well
we're glad you all today this is a great
mix of career and money and Ken can
definitely help you on that career side
but I think the main problem right now
is you're staring at a mountain of debt
in a high cost of living area and so so
do you think you're not making enough
money for where you're at
100 yes what is your income
uh so I'm at 75
what do you do
operations
um for uh real estate on the back end of
real estate teams
okay
and are you wanting to switch careers
are you happy in your career but you
just want to make more money in that
same type of role
it could do is to become a nurse but
that will take quite a while to get
there
um but on like a day-to-day basis I
really like I enjoy what I do okay yeah
the nurse dream is great but right now
we're just going to exacerbate the
problem if we go another 150 Grand into
debt and now we're staring at 300 Grand
there's no amount of money that's going
to make that worth it and so until we
can cash flow that nursing program I'm
going to pause and go how do we stack up
as much cash as possible maybe it's an
extra job maybe it's getting a different
role in that field so that we have some
margin to throw at the debt
okay
that makes sense
um so what do you
then what so how do you let's let's talk
about the costs like well let's let's
start I'm going to dig a little bit for
and George I'm just digging here for you
on this but but what's the cost of
living what is it what is your mortgage
because that's if it's just if you're
pointing to that as a big hindrance to
you being able to to uh I mean you're
not even you're not even meeting ends
meet each month you're you're you're no
so how much are you paying for rent or
mortgage
for the smallest thing I could find um I
bring home uh about on the main job uh
40 4100
um and then yeah
um doing extra jobs what's your what's
your minimum payments on all that debt
uh oh um it ends up being
uh fifteen hundred are you married or
single
divorced
and uh you've looked everywhere where
you are you got the cheapest thing in
that area so now your only options are
if you stay in this current role as you
move further out but then now that
creates uh some life changes as well a
commute correct
it does and so I'm mostly remote
um which is kind of a weird thing
um so I moved out here to be closer but
I am still mostly remote
um but we are very
um where I'm located there's not uh any
further out it actually gets more
expensive for quite a while what about a
roommate
uh I don't know many people here uh I
didn't ask you that I asked you what
about a roommate let me just throw a
concept at you if you get a roommate to
pick up half the rent you just got an
eleven hundred dollar a month raise
you know you'd get a two bedroom okay
hold on a second I was are you in a one
bedroom
I am I'm in a one bedroom two bedroom's
gonna go all right I apologize I can
understand how you're like why this Ken
guy is a little weird I do I get a bunk
bed
I almost can't I'd almost entertain it
though yeah I mean at this point yeah
Sarah here's the harsh reality I just
did the math for you ninety percent of
your take-home pay is gone as soon as
you pay rent and cover your minimum
payments and I can't I can't see you
continue going down this hole and so we
have to do something drastic so what
types of debt do you have in that 141 is
there anything that we could sell like a
car
as for my cars at night I had nine
thousand left on that
um there's 21 in the credit card stuff
uh 26 to the IRS and then uh 83 in
student loans okay what's the current
worth those are coming back in uh oh and
what I owe on it I mean I I would
probably have to pay a thousand to get
rid of it oh
if you're remote could you just move to
a different state a different area where
rent is super cheap
I've asked them they refuse I might look
at a different job time for a different
job that is the only that's the only
momentum Builder you've got right now
unless you're working a second or a
third job
you gotta have more like I'm piecing it
together yeah but you gotta have
dramatically more income and
dramatically less expenses and the only
place to do that based on what you've
told George is the living arrangements
if you could move somewhere else get a
job making what you're making in another
state and then you get a roommate you
know and it's so let's say you get a two
bedroom for 1500 and you get a roommate
and split that now all of a sudden you
got some momentum you got some margin
and we get a second or third job on top
of that yeah exactly and so we have both
sides of this thing now we have a
thousand bucks to throw at the debt
instead of negative 300 which is
probably where you're at now I'm not
afraid of working I'm working I believe
that right now we we want to see Sarah
win and sometimes it takes doing really
hard stuff for a little while and maybe
one day you're gonna be back in the Bay
Area but you're probably gonna be making
150 or 200 if we're going to be back
there because that's kind of what you
need to make to survive out there
and so making 75. you could make 75 work
if you didn't have 140 Grand in debt and
so we've got to go clean up this mess
and do what it takes and that might mean
saying hey I'm sorry I love this role
but right now I can't even make ends
making 75 so I've got to go find
something else I can do where I can make
a hundred and Sarah in a cheaper living
area I know that what we're suggesting
is going to uproot you and it's not
comfortable but I will tell you if you
can switch your mind
from all the things that you've got to
do now an uncomfortable pull-up routes
find a job move to a new place blah blah
blah but I if you can switch it to this
gets me closer to being a nurse
I think it's I think it'll help you all
of these moves that we just recommended
get you that much closer to being a
nurse
because when you're debt free and you
have an emergency fund you can cash flow
your way through that nursing program
what we're asking you to do while
stressful yes is way less stressful than
what you're dealing with every month
100 if you do the math on you being in
the hole every single month and add up
what that is per year you're gonna go oh
my gosh I'm gonna continue to go into
debt while this interest racks up which
is insane on those credit cards alone
and that I couldn't breathe doing that I
would do whatever it took to get out of
that and we want to help you and so I'm
going to give you one year of Financial
Peace University and one year of every
dollar premium so that you have a little
hope you have a motivation you have
people walking alongside of you and if
you join that FPU class maybe you'll
meet someone and they'll go hey I'm
looking for roommate too I'm trying to
get out of debt that would be amazing
oh that's wonderful well that's virtual
there you go that's wonderful it's so
great to have you in this FPU class and
I'm glad you're there uh and you'll have
a year of every dollar as well because
you're in there might I recommend George
in the class yeah see if anybody in your
class
uh knows of an open job in the company
that they're working on or proximity
principles let's do a little proximity
principle in your class and let's just
see yeah if we might find Sarah a place
to land I love it and for those of you
listening and you're a little jealous
because Sarah just got some free stuff
you can go check out a sweet deal we
have right now at everydollar.com George
because I'm I'm in with the team 15
bucks off a premium subscription and a
14 day free trial to check it out
there's some amazing tools connect to
your face to know George check planning
all of it all you need to go uh do is go
to everydollar.com George and check that
out we want to see all of you in with
you're such a big deal I'm a giver 10.
you really are this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey George Campbell here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsey
personality George Campbell Join This
Hour by Ken Coleman host of the Ken
Coleman show and we're here for you
America to help you take the right next
step with your work life and with your
money life the number to call is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five Alfonso kicks us off in D.C
Alfonso welcome
hello gentlemen thank you so much for
having me sure how can we help
um well first I just want to give a
quick shout out to the man who's not
here great pleasure to talk to you guys
but I am a bleeding heart a liberal who
thinks Dave Ramsey is a great American
hero and uh just wanna love to hear that
hold on a second did you say you're a
bleeding heart liberal
I I am attacks the rich liberal the
things Dave Ramsey is the Greatest
American Hero when it comes to finance
that is fantastic I thought that's what
you said uh and uh okay wow I gotta tell
you the message I will pass out I'll
just throw one more thing out there I
got a great business idea I want to
connect with Dave about but anyway yeah
well that's not gonna happen but anyway
hey Ken has a lot of them too and Dave
shuts those down yeah you should hear my
ideas
um well anyway to my question gentlemen
thank you so much for having me and my
family really does appreciate both of
you as well and uh you taught my
children a lot about financial
responsibility we're very grateful for
it
um so my mother is 80 plus years old
um my dad owned his own business and
struggled towards the end and uh
thankfully there was a real estate
property we were able to sell and my mom
has about five hundred thousand dollars
uh in cash assets which is the majority
of our assets we have a high interest
savings account because she's battling
cancer and we just don't know uh what
needs she's gonna have I have some
family members putting pressure on me to
invest that thinking that you know the
Market's selling off swing and there's a
view out there that's going to keep
doing that my view is with the health
challenge that not not knowing where
that's going to go safest bet to keep it
in uh online high interest savings
account would love your advice gentlemen
that is a great question well I'm so
sorry to hear about your mom that's
tough what has been the kind of
prognosis diagnosis do we know anything
yeah uh we don't know if it's in one
year five years to eight years but it is
terminal okay
so to your question 500 Grand is this
all FDIC insured is it across two
accounts or is there a joint folks on
the account to keep it safe across
multiple accounts okay all FDA C insured
okay great and I'm sure the interest
rate on that is about what four percent
or so right now that's actually five
five point four right now amazing okay
yeah so the question of should I invest
this money we know that we're may need
this money in the next few years exactly
and therefore I'm with you on this and
that the family's going hey we should
invest this we're not this is not a
money making scheme right now we're not
trying to retire off of this money we
want to make sure that we have it liquid
to help Mom and cover any related costs
that come our way and as you know the
cost can be astronomical as you get to
you know end of life care and so I want
to keep that money accessible to protect
our family uh from the other wealth that
we're trying to build
all right so I think you're doing the
right things man I'm so sorry you're
dealing with this how old are you
uh I am gonna turn 40 uh late 40s let's
say okay man well I cannot imagine going
through something like that you sound
like you're in in good spirits and uh
you're a great son for thinking about
this stuff and calling in with the
question but I would definitely not be
investing this money right now and if it
turns out that you could have made
another you know three percent if you
had invested in the stock market big
whoop I want to sleep well at night
knowing that my mom is taking care of
and we've got the funds to take care of
her so that's my take take it or leave
it Lindsay's up next in NYC Lindsay
welcome to the show
um I am thankful you guys took my call
thanks sure what's going on
yeah so um my husband and I have been
married for a few years and um we found
out recently that the only way that
we're going to uh probably be able to
like have a kid is through IBS which is
incredibly expensive and we've been
saving up money for a house because you
know New York City is so expensive
um and so we've got a little bit saved
but it feels like the expenses here so
much it's so hard to get ahead
um and so that's IVs treatment if it
does work you know multiple rounds lots
of money so we are like okay that takes
out our whole saving for the house
specifically
um so we were like
uh talking with my parents about it and
my grandmother passed away recently and
they used to have a uh they have a an
apartment in their home
um like she used to stay in
um and so that that apartment is free
and they said well we would love for you
to come and live with us
um for free but they live in the middle
of nowhere
um like absolutely like no jobs
basically accepted unless you want to
work it like
um you know the gas station it's like a
Dollar General situation
a big company out there okay
um but what if one of us you know gets
laid off because of all these layoffs
that happen and so I'm kind of thinking
about okay if we did then we're not in
New York City we don't have you know
that ability to kind of get another job
quickly
um so there's like gives it give and
take we'd have free rent we'd have
everything there but would it really get
us ahead Lindsay what do you do in Tech
but you and your husband
yeah so I am in operations and so
um I I make uh like 130 a year and then
my husband is in sales and he makes
about 60 before like day okay um before
his uh yeah so here's the deal I am in
no way saying that you need to move to
you know the middle of nowhere but what
changed for me
um was the fact that you're both remote
and in Tech and I will tell you that um
because I focus on work issues all the
time uh I give a lot of work news
updates on the Ken Cohen Show and I will
tell you that
um we're seeing over the last year when
there have been some of the larger big
tech companies that have laid people off
that those Tech workers are getting new
jobs within a month the tech industry is
still hot hot hot and so I don't think
that's something you need to be afraid
of and I don't think you need to be in
New York City to get a tech job
especially if you're remote so that does
not mean that I think you need to move
to the middle of nowhere however if your
housing cost is the number one strap
that's cash strapping you guys to be
able to cash flow IVF I'm absolutely
moving to a different place a different
Locale where we can do our jobs it's not
the middle of nowhere but it greatly
reduces our living expenses to allow us
to cash flow IVs Stacy and I went
through the infertility journey and I
just want to tell you it's brutal
and and I do understand what your
husband is feeling I cannot tell you
that I know what you're feeling but my
wife could tell you she understands what
you're feeling and this is an all-in
proposition you need to be healthy which
means mentally to go through this
and it's still not a guarantee so if
it's me I'm packing up and I'm moving to
a different place making an adventure I
can always relocate back to New York
City yeah I think this could be a fun
little adventure and if it means you can
get that IVF treatment cash flowed and
then get into a house I think we got to
focus on one or the other right now
because that's a lot it needs to be the
IVF right now I would focus on the IVF
once we get that figured out then home
ownership would be the next thing down
the road and you guys will get there and
it sounds like you're willing to do
whatever it takes and for that you have
my utmost respect this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
this hour it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Caleb joins us up next in Atlanta Caleb
welcome to the show
hey guys thanks uh for taking my call
um can one say go dogs go dogs
um yeah
my wife and I were on a baby step four
five and six a couple years ago we had a
paid off house
mid-2021 we were both in different jobs
making a little bit more money uh fast
forward to now uh we got a little bit
bigger for our britches and uh two years
ago we bought a little bit of a bigger
house uh put a lot of equity into it up
front rolling the paid off house into it
but we did take a mortgage back on and
since then we've both had job changes
that were both making a little bit less
money than we were we've also got
a child in daycare now that we didn't
have prior we've also just had our
second baby as well we're finding it
tougher each month for us to balance our
budget we've had to kind of go into the
savings a little bit to kind of slow
things out and so we're kind of at a
point where we're kind of at one of two
choices do we sell our house and
downsize and try to just get into a
house that we can pay off up front and
be debt free it might mean moving
further out from our work and having a
little bit more of a commute or do we
kind of focus on trying to bring the
income back up to maybe closer to where
it was
I'm leaning towards more income George
what do you think that's definitely the
first move I'd make that selling the
house is always the last ditch effort if
we can't get out of this hole and it
feels hopeless you have that option but
it's never my first option I go hey for
sure go sell the house that's a lot of
time it's a lot of money and uh the the
question is can you guys get the income
up to where this house becomes 25 of
your take-home pay and how long would
that take
is possible my wife was laid off last
year and so her neck the job she found
after getting laid off pays her about
ten thousand less I'm kind of in a new
role uh doing sales for the first time
so my income is way down so it's
possible over time if I stick with sales
and the pipeline gets built up the
income will kind of get back closer to
where it was a year or two ago uh I just
don't know how long that's going to take
for us to to get there now why did you
move into a sales role
to try something different uh uh it's
something I'd always kind of been
interested in and
we're in a place that's worth giving it
a try it was with people I know and
trusted and just wanted to to try
something different how long have you
been in that role
about three months and so far how's it
feeling
uh depends on the day
yeah but tell me more
um
aspects of it I love not being in an
office I love being out and about
meeting people making relationships I'm
very relational uh love solving people's
problems and serving them
um emotionally I have struggled with the
up and down kind of nature of sales both
from yes and no being told yes and no by
a customer but also the financial you
know kind of uncertainty of it too no
question what are you selling I'll sell
residential and Commercial paint sales
okay
um
if I were you I would be looking at
better sales job opportunities something
that has a little bit higher margin
um you know I I don't claim to know that
the commercial and residential paint
sales industry but my guess is is not a
huge amount of margin that you'd have to
sell a whole lot to make a whole lot
more is that true or false
that's fairly true I work for one of the
larger companies in the city and we only
have two percent of the market it's a
very saturated Market it's very
competitive yeah I would at least it's
worth kicking the tires on sales
opportunities where you've got a product
or a service that is it's just a much
more lucrative industry you're not in a
very lucrative industry for sales and so
that's going to be discouraging and uh
and so I think that's I want to give it
back to George on the money side of
things I still don't think you need to
sell your house
um but I do think that both of you need
to go wait a second
just because I got laid off for talking
about your wife just because you tried
this new sales idea and it's not great
doesn't mean that we're stuck we're not
stuck I mean we live in a job economy
right now in America where it is very
normal for people to move on and I would
be considering other sales jobs where
you've got a much much better
opportunity when I talk about
opportunity I mean a ladder to grow and
the margin's higher so you can make more
money right out of the gate I'd be I'd
be looking for that for your wife same
deal whatever she was doing in the past
just because she got laid off doesn't
mean she's a failure and now you guys do
have jobs so we're not scrambling so it
takes the pressure off and now we look
for something that's better because if
you guys just increase your income and
even if you both got to work second jobs
for right now that's another thing that
I I always pull out of the old tool belt
to say that's gonna create more
financial margin for a season even
though it may take more of your time so
I think you got to look at everything
right now
as it relates to increasing income
before we decide to sell the house
sure Caleb what is your mortgage
compared to your take-home pay
um our gross well our gross overall my
life makes 70 since I'm new to the sales
um I have a very low base obviously and
it's heavy commission
um but you know a couple years ago
before we both counted this we were
combined household income of about 160.
um our house payment each month's about
9.50 yeah the house payment doesn't seem
like it's killing it which makes me go
let's not you know if it's any broke
don't fix it and so making the house
payment for 9.50 I want to see you guys
bringing home four grand a month take
home which feels very reasonable
yeah and so you've got daycare there's
other expenses I understand that can put
people in a pinch but the house doesn't
seem like the issue here it's how do we
continue with these baby steps get this
baby step three emergency fund done have
the margin to invest 15 and realize
daycare is not forever it's gonna be a
few years
and how do we kind of float this next
five years or however long it is until
we have a little more margin to do the
other things we want to do like pay off
the house early and save for college
that makes sense and that was why I
wanted some some guidance we've been on
the fence and it while paying selling
downsizing the house would maybe
immediately solve some of the money
problems it's a major decision to make
and so we kind of want to exhaust all of
our options before we go that far yeah
I'm with you I mean if you said my
mortgage is three thousand dollars a
month and we we take home four thousand
I'd be like this thing's got to go today
but it didn't feel like that was the
problem and also it's kind of a shortcut
and I'm not against you selling things
to get out of debt I think that can be
great but a lot of times we gotta look
at the root issue which is our Behavior
it's our income that's coming in we got
to really focus on those pieces before
we go to the kind of get out of jail
free cards I'm a simple math guy because
you know I'm not very bright George
that's not true that's really true and
uh so I sit there and I go all right
what's the amount of money that if I
could just snap my fingers and it
appeared in our bank account every month
it would allow us to finish out that
emergency fund or whatever baby step
you're on or it would give us that
margin what's that number all right and
so let's just say it's
600 bucks a month I'm just randomly
saying that but that's the way I I try
to break these scary complex decisions
down to something simple okay if we had
if we could put 600 a month into our
emergency fund or whatever we could
speed through it and then so then I'd go
all right now I can understand I can
solve for 600 a month yeah and reverse
engineer it from there and that's what I
like to do with the baby steps when
people call in and they go hey it's
going to take me six years to get out of
debt I go that sucks doesn't it they go
yeah I go how do we speed that up what
if you did it in two years how much
would you have to put towards the debt
every month that's what I like to do in
order to do it and they go well I need
to make an extra thousand bucks a month
right now we got a solvable problem how
do we make an extra thousand bucks a
month from cutting expenses to making
more side jobs all those things we can
create that margin to where we can
breathe now we've got some hope we see
the light at the end of the tunnel and
we turned a hopeless situation with just
some basic facts figures and a little
bit of grit and sacrifice we can get out
of this thing once and for all yep you
guys can do it what we do on the show
here Caleb you got it get after it baby
that's just good advice right there that
solves most problems get after it there
we go that's old school advice from Ken
Coleman it's like Larry the Cable Guy's
cousin get after it get after it get her
done hey it works you know maybe not the
best advice not the most tactical but I
feel inspired Ken thank you this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsay we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
this hour the number to call is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
again I want to talk about a concept
with you that is inspiring to many
people and that is compound interest
um yeah it's something that you've you
talk about a lot I do on your show I
wake up I think about it and it's the
last thing I think about before I go to
bed now Albert Einstein I don't know if
he actually said this quote but if you
Google it it they say he said it he said
that compound interest is the eighth
wonder of the world wow and when I
hosted the high school curriculum can
the students get so excited when they
see the charts the graphs of what
compound countries cannot and it's well
it's a wealth building superpower that
people don't fully understand so I just
wanted to unpack it for people not
because I'm a giant nerd which I am but
also because I think it will inspire a
lot of people to go I gotta get out of
debt and start investing what have I
been doing I gotta up my investing to 15
instead of this measly three percent
this is amazing
so what is compound interest well it is
the interest you earn from the original
amount aka the principal of an
investment plus any interest you've
already made through that investment so
your interest earns interest and so that
is the kind of compounding growth effect
that happens and I can walk through this
with a really fun example Ken you want
to do that yeah but before we do that
since you were dropping big names and
quotes huge names I'll see your Einstein
quote and raise it with a Ben Franklin
because I think that I think Ben got it
money makes money and the money that
money makes makes money did Ben Franklin
really say that it's what it says right
here in this room
lyric what is with your cynicism towards
famous people's quotes I just feel like
that we attribute a lot of random quotes
to these old guys I'm like we don't know
that they said that I don't know that
this is helping the viewer or The
Listener I apologize dear listener dude
I just can't picture it because here we
are trying to teach you something and we
quote famous people and then George
immediately puts doubt on it I apologize
friends I apologize here's the thing
they're confusing our listener and
viewer George I'm picturing the
forefathers going hey let's sit around
and come up with fun tweets that one day
people will Quote us by no no see
there's where everything falls apart now
I understand
Ben Franklin didn't think in tweets
there wasn't such a thing as Twitter Ben
Franklin read he read some more books
and stuff and he talked to other smart
people got it all right thank you for
that go ahead and show me this very
exciting here's a quick example if you
invest ten thousand dollars and you get
a 10 annual return which by the way
people go what do you get a 10 return if
you look at the S P 500 which
essentially is The Benchmark index for
the stock market it's the top 500
companies uh if you look at that the
average return has been 10 to 12 percent
since its Inception
so this is not an outrageous claim that
you could get a 10 average annual return
not every year some years it may be down
22 percent some years it's up 20 who
knows uh but that ten ten thousand
dollars at a ten percent return and if
you just leave that ten thousand alone
for 40 years here's what happens at year
one you're at ten thousand year ten
you're almost at 26. by year 20 you're
at 67 000. 30 years in you're at 175 000
and then 40 years in you're at 452 000
is that not amazing that's fantastic and
remember you only put in ten
and so the total growth on that was 442
000 of money that you didn't put in it
was just your interest earning interest
so how does that happen well let's talk
through an example of this and the power
of starting early because a lot of
people there they aren't maybe they're
not there yet Ken either they have debt
they don't have the emergency fund
they're in their 40s or 50s or 60s they
feel like it's too late they feel like
they don't have the knowledge let's take
someone my age George I'm 48. oh boy all
right I wasn't gonna go that old Ken I
was gonna go well the example here you
see you can change the numbers on the
example but let's say this guy Ben who
starts at 21. Brian Kidd he his parents
went through FPU he did this stuff and
he invests 2 400 bucks a year
you got that just 2400 2400 a year it's
not a lot that's 200 a month yeah and he
stops contributing at age 30. so from 21
to 30 2400 bucks a year the total amount
he contributed was 21 600 bucks now his
buddy Joey a little older he started
investing at age 30 and he invests 2 400
a year as well and he contributes until
he is 67. so instead of nine years he
contributes for 37 years and the total
amount he contributes 88 800.
now in your mind Ken without doing math
you're going well Joey's got to have
more Joey's ahead yeah he invested for a
lot longer period of time you would be
what's known as wrong because at age 67
Ben's investment remember his 21 000 he
put in has grown to 2.1 million dollars
Joey's investment has grown to 1.2
million dollars so that nine-year
difference that nine-year Gap from when
Ben started to when Joey started was a
difference of close to one million
dollars is that not wild it's crazy now
some people hear that and they go well
wait a second is it too late for me no
because what about the guy who started
at 30. the best time to plant a tree was
20 years ago the next best time is today
and so regardless of where you're at you
got to start and if you're 50 well still
if you let's say it's 70 years old you
still have 20 years of compound growth
to take advantage of and if you're young
and you follow this plan you go hey what
if I could graduate debt free what if I
could get out of all my debt cut up the
cards have an emergency fund begin
investing 15 within normal income you're
going to be a multi millionaire if you
just start when you're out of college
and so regardless of your age the key
here is to get started as soon as you
can and the right time to start
investing Ken is once you're out of
Consumer Debt with a fully funded
emergency fund now a lot of people get
mad at us for this because they go oh my
gosh you're going to make me throw away
the company match part of the reason you
don't have the margin to invest 15 is
because you're carrying all this debt
your broke living paycheck to paycheck
and you're trying to get this three
percent match what if for a season you
paused you went down to zero on the
match zero on your investing so that you
had more margin to throw at the debt now
we're added at faster and we're back to
15 once we come back to investing so
it's a powerful powerful principle to
take advantage of compound interest
compound growth capital appreciation
whatever nerdy word you want to throw on
it and the key is you don't have to be a
genius investor I mean our millionaire
study found that most of them were
mediocre investors that just invested
consistently over a long period of time
in a 401k and a Roth IRA in growth stock
mutual funds and they didn't even pick
the best ones they just went all right
this is not a super volatile investment
it's not a single stock it's not crypto
I'm just going to invest in my
retirement plan and they became
millionaires by doing that and the
average age was 49 so you're right on
track Ken look at that we started at 49.
no they became millionaire average age
for the millionaires in our study of
over 10 000. I see so somewhere younger
some were older gotcha but it just goes
to show you if you just follow a proven
plan you don't have to make a bajillion
dollars or be a doctor or a lawyer you
can build wealth on your terms uh
without having to strike it rich or get
an inheritance or do all these crazy
things so that's encouraging to me Ken I
hope it encourages you yeah absolutely I
feel very encouraged well we've come a
long way I mean moments ago I was being
haranged for my Ben Franklin
quote commentary no not at all you you
you I I is harangue the proper usage
there I don't know I just I always use
big words when I hang out with you to
impress you I was giving you a hard time
for your cynicism towards historical
quotes I didn't question that Albert
Einstein said that all right you did and
then you questioned it Ben Franklin said
it I listen I'm a man of the people I
have to look out for our for our
audience well also you're confused by
you you're a history nerd and so I can't
go Toe to Toe with you guys to call each
other names I don't understand the name
calling I don't get it I'm a history
nerd I can count on one finger how many
biographies I've read and I think it was
a spark notes from the Steve Jobs
oh I love a good biography well let's
switch gears count yes I got to clear
something up here if you listen to the
show for 10 seconds you you'll find out
we are not a fan of debt and some people
just don't understand that they think
that you need debt and credit cards to
build your credit because you need a
good credit score to buy a house and
that is wrong
and I say that with great Authority
because I bought a house and I got a
mortgage without a credit score so the
truth is if you're living a debt-free
lifestyle eventually you won't have any
credit score it's a natural byproduct of
getting out of debt and closing your
accounts so when you're ready to buy a
house you gotta find a good lender like
our friends at Churchill Mortgage who
can do what's called manual underwriting
instead of automated underwriting so
this is a no score loan where they
personally review your financial history
to approve you for a mortgage it's very
old-timey I like it and that way you can
avoid the credit score game altogether
and this may sound crazy to people but
the best plan for your future is to
avoid debt save a big down payment and
get a real estate agent who will help
you find a house you can actually afford
and we recommend agents who are Ramsay
trusted meaning their top performers
with years of experience helping people
like you buy homes the right way so none
of this is impossible you can buy a
house without a credit score you can
find a house that'll be a blessing not a
financial burden and you can find a
trustworthy real estate agent who will
help you do all of that by going to
ramseysolutions.com
agent that's ramseysolutions.com agent
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by my good friend
Ken Coleman our question of the day is
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services if you own rental
properties neighborly's local Real
Property Management offices can manage
them and help optimize your Roi and
peace of mind go to neighborly.com to
schedule a consultation with Real
Property Management Pros near you
today's question comes from Mitchell in
Florida writes I'm looking for advice on
paying off my car loan I took out a
three-year loan last year for twenty
five thousand dollars and have a monthly
payment of seven hundred and fifteen
dollars and one cent at a 1.9 percent
interest rate it was a brand new 2022
Mazda 3. when I got the car loan I was
trying to help improve my credit also
which stands at 7 20. I have 47 000
available in cash that's sitting in a
4.5
high yield savings account my question
is do I use the 47 000 to pay it off or
keep using my paychecks and letting the
47 000 keep making me money from the
interest I feel like that is a softball
to you George so I just tossed it to you
swing away my friend well you know I I'm
a big fan of t-ball Cannon this one's
right there softball was the
announcement that's okay because it's
that easy it's right there it's on the
TV okay you need all the help you can
get I acknowledge thank you yeah okay so
this is this is actually a tough
question to answer Ken not because of
the numbers because the the truth is you
know he's got 25 000 alone he has 47 000
in cash a third grader is doing the math
going oh he should just go pay the car
loan off he has the money to do it the
rub here is he thinks it's a money
making scheme to make four percent on
his money in the bank correct make an
interest instead of paying off the two
percent low interest debt right and this
is a problem a lot of Americans are
facing right now
uh because they go well I would be an
idiot to pay off the low interest debt
and I'm going you'd be an idiot to hang
on to debt like a pet thinking that it's
some kind of money making scheme and so
if you pay off that car loan guess what
you have freed up 715 guess what you can
do with that money you can now invest
that money and make possibly way more
than four and a half percent in the
stock market in your retirement accounts
well that's guaranteed so I would uh of
course you're gonna need a car but if
you paid off that car loan
um depending on what the car is worth
you know you sell that thing or keep it
depending on your income that'll put you
in a great financial spot so you're also
concerned about your credit score if
you've listened to this show you know I
don't give two rips about the credit
score I don't want you to have a bad
score but when you get out of debt you
just all of a sudden don't have one six
and six or twelve months later and I
would just live without a credit score
pay cash for your car if you need to get
a house do manual underwriting you can
rent cars and hotels and do all that
stuff without a credit score and I've
done it I've lived it Ken Coleman has
two
and I wish you the best in this debt
payoff Journey but I would not keep
playing this game to try to make a
little bit of money right now it's not
worth it no I I love that advice I I
just look at it as a 700 race there we
go
that's where I go 715 dollars in one
penny to be precise the one penny is
what really that's the race and uh
that's a game changer what you decide to
do with that to your employee investing
it's going to end up paying off way
higher yeah I mean when you don't have
any debt and then you can really sock
away money in savings and Investments
that's when that's the real money making
scheme there Ken not giving your money
to lenders and trying to like play some
Arbitrage game you're not doing that all
right Frank is up next in Mobile Alabama
Frank welcome to the show
well thank you for taking my call sure
how can we help
well I had a medical issue uh two years
ago lost my job
uh been hanging on hanging on my
little emergency fund while I was
working my snowball
debt
was depleted like almost immediately is
um anyway
I haven't been able to pay my credit
card through my little Local Credit
Union here
and they're negotiating and they're
offered
about 50 51 percent
of what I owe okay should I take that or
do you think there's more room for
negotiation
I would take it do you have the money to
pay it
I can scrape that together I would
scrape it together and be done with it
and call it a blessing and move on with
my life
yeah right now is not the time to try to
haggle I mean you owed this money
they're willing to give you some grace
and mercy here and say hey we'll take
half of it if you got it and for that
reason I'm Gonna Take It
thank you I I was just kind of looking
for some guidance I've been listening to
guys for years and will that get you
debt free I actually
I still got the house but other than
that yeah the wife's got some little
card stuff but let's cut up the cards
and pay these things off what does she
have on her cards
I think like four grand are they is it
in collections or is it just sitting on
the balance
no we've been able to hang on to those
current so we're going to start knocking
them out now that this one's
out of the way and I do have a little
bit of income coming in finally
are you working full-time right now
because you said you were unable to
foreign medically disabled okay
permanently it just went through wow and
your wife after 15 months now is that
going to give you more margin with
disability payments
it'll let us
keep current with hers so we can pay
them all
and be debt free is she working
she's unable to work due to a medical
condition my goodness is she getting any
disability gazelle right out from under
us yeah that's tough
um why is she why it sounds like you
said the wife has cards do you guys have
separate finances are you guys on the
same page and in the same bank account
well we have a joint but
I cannot seem to uh finagle her head
around get rid of them so like a little
security blanket no well it's not a
security blanket it's a weighted blanket
isn't it
that's what I've been trying to show her
with this one I don't know how you're
sleeping at night under that security
blanket quote unquote when you're on
disability you can't work and you have
all these payments you got to make
it's about 23 interest probably
does she does she feel what you feel the
way you started the call is it kind of
sounded like a country song Frank like
I'm just hanging on hanging on hanging
on and that's exhausting right
yeah
it is
and does she feel that way
no she just thinks you know
everything is fine and that's what I
thought she steps to we're taking uh
steps to
how old are you in a right direction
we're both in our 50s okay and uh you're
unofficially retired because you're
unable to work so what does the next 10
years look like for you guys
have you talked about that I'm gonna
remain debt free and if we can't get
together on this you can't remain debt
free unless she decides to become debt
free because it's we
y'all are married
the men have to not be that but I don't
want that but it may have to be
well I think you're gonna have to have a
hard conversation and go listen this is
really hard on me I'm scared we're not
safe you think we're safe with the
security blanket of a credit card I want
to be completely debt free we don't have
a lot of income coming in all we have is
this disability to get us by for the
next who knows how many years and I want
to get to safety I want to get to
financial peace and I'm willing to do
whatever it takes are you in
and I want you to have a little bit of
urgency in your voice when you say it
okay
because I want you guys to have some
dignity in retirement and not just go
well we're just hanging on we've been
hanging on like Eeyore is your spirit
animal over here I want better for you
guys and it sounds like you guys lost
hope a little while back and um we want
to put a little pep in your step give
you some mojo back and go you can have a
great life but it's going to take a
little bit of short-term sacrifice
so if there's anything you guys can even
do from home I don't know what that
looks like with your medical conditions
and disabilities but I don't want you
just relying on the government giving
you scraps off the table trying to just
get by you're worth more than that Frank
that's all I gotta say Ken yeah I
couldn't agree more Frank it's time to
make some real changes in your life and
this is a heart-to-heart conversation
you guys aren't on the same page and
that's a real problem
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books my thanks to Ken Coleman my
co-host and all the folks in the booth
keeping the show float there's about 4
000 of them in there that make us look
good and you America thank you so much
for listening we'll be back before you
know it
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell and joined by Ken Coleman this
hour this is your show America we are
here to help you take the right next
step in your work life and your money
life the number to call is triple eight
eight two five five two two five and if
you're a listener of this show whether
long time or you're just checking it out
if you like this show this is a free
show and I want to ask you to do one
thing that's also free that won't take
much of your time and that is to
consider hitting the Subscribe button
the follow button leaving us a review
wherever you're listening and sharing
the show with a friend we like to joke
that we have almost no marketing budget
for the show because you guys are the
marketing budget you telling people to
listen to the show to check it out
that's what actually works instead of
some ad scrolling in your Instagram and
so we so appreciate all of you who have
encouraged your friends to listen to
this to give them some hope and
motivation across their life whether
it's work money or relationships let's
get to the phones James is up first in
Springfield James welcome to the show
hey guys how you doing great how can we
help
hey so I had a quick question
um I did feel super motivated so I
thought I called it in super glad I got
through to you guys
um so my first big milestone on baby
step two is complete uh my wife got her
VA disability rating and the back pay
from February so as an early birthday
present
um it's more birthdays later in July she
helped me pay off the remaining balance
on my motorcycle so that was awesome wow
um so question I have a mini HELOC for I
know Ewok I hate it didn't want to do it
but I needed 16 000 to get a new heater
for my house in Alaska when we were
still up there
um and nobody else would give us that
much money well I have that is about a
twelve thousand dollar balance right now
with a variable apy that caps out at
around 10 percent and it's been capped
out for a minute now
um and then my truck has about 12 300
left on the loan so
they fluctuate one goes lower and then
like two months later the other one's
higher just because they're so close
um in that kind of situation is it okay
to go with the one with the flex or the
variable apy versus the fixed
just to get rid of it quicker what so
you have two loans total
uh there's a couple more but
um one of them's a little bit less than
that uh it's right around the tenth hour
nine thousand dollar Mark and that's our
next one that we're focusing on okay
what kind of debt is that estimating
about four months it's
an embarrassment um
uh The Traveler
um
the dumb things where you go to the
seminar and you sign up I can't even
remember what it's called Uh
a timeshare
yes a traveler time sir thank you okay
um it's one of those I've tried to get
out of it but without getting deep into
a hole and owning somebody that I don't
even know a bunch of money I was like
you know what I'd rather just keep the
points because I can at least use them
for hotel stays when we go visit family
because we're both from the West Coast
at the military station here in Missouri
right now so okay so we're knocking out
the traveler time share and then you're
like hey I've got the HELOC and the
truck they're both about the same
balance one's variable one's fixed or I
just attack the fix first
um yeah at that point since they're
about the same balance I would attack
the one with the variable uh since
that's that's the ankle biter stressing
you out right now but truthfully it
won't matter much financially because
you're attacking this thing so
aggressively how quickly will you be
completely debt free
um so I'm set to PCS this year
um when I left Alaska and came to
Missouri I made a good chunk of change
and a team of about ten thousand dollars
of uh hey here's your money back for
driving half your belongings across the
country and through Canada and so I'm
expecting I'm going back to Alaska later
this year so I'm expecting around the
same amount and that should in theory
knock out that traveler thing and then
my wife now with her VA rating
um she's getting just over a thousand a
month starting
this month or next month so that's going
to knock out that HELOC in about 10 or
11 months plus probably sooner because
we're going to throw more on top of it
of course okay what's the truck worth
um do you work about 25. man I mean
here's a scenario just throwing it out
there thought about it I've thought
about it but I have a trailer that I
have to get some of my belongings up to
Alaska myself with
is there any other way to get those
belongings out there
no so our our
um could you rent a truck would that be
cheaper really a whole lot
oh no no no no I've looked into that as
well that's that's a pretty penny to get
like a U-Haul or something like that I'm
just saying dude I mean if there's any
way if you could sell this truck and get
rid of the truck loan get rid of the
HELOC and one Fell Swoop dude freedom is
right there why wait a year or two I'm
figuring out the belonging situation
I don't know I'm listening I'm trying to
be very polite over here I'm sitting
here sitting here sitting here sitting
here well I got to say something you
just you're burying the lead here that
the truck is worth twice you've got to
sell the truck and get a cheaper truck
then you can drive the stuff if that's
if that's the only way to get your stuff
to Alaska could still do it with a
cheaper truck
good I know the truck and you know
sustain an eight-year-old sitting in the
back with the two dogs I've heard that
trucks can hold eight-year-olds and dogs
and you can get a pre-purchase
inspection you can't that they can you
get a ten thousand dollar truck this
truck's gone you're trying to hold on to
this truck you got every excuse in the
world so why you need to hold on to this
truck and the truth is you could sell it
and you can find a way to get those
belongings to Alaska I don't think
you've thought of everything
just because like I said I've thought
about it and I've looked at the market
around here
um up in the St Louis area which is
worse I just I need to find something in
the area that would be reasonable for me
to do that so I'll look at it again how
much do you owe on the truck when I have
time
uh 12.
yeah and you you think you could get 25
for it
uh according to KBB it puts it right
between 24 and 26 I'll average it out at
25. okay then that's the fact that
you've looked that up tells me you've
thought about it yeah and you need to
look at what you market for 15 to 17.
what can you get for 15 to 17. that'll
get you a whole lot of that'll get you
to Alaska I guarantee you an
eight-year-old and a dog will be able to
fit in those trucks dude I look at used
cars all the time all the time
uh I'm I'm just challenging you on this
because George is right I'm with George
there's a lot of vehicles that can tow a
trailer and so really look at what you
really need and what will get you from A
to B because it's really this one time
scenario we got to get some belongings
over from A to B that's it but I don't
think that's worth being in debt for a
year or two longer so that's what I'm
kind of weighing and so you can do what
you want but uh you know you asked for
Our advice and we gave it to you
straight but man if freedom is right
around the corner and I've got to figure
out how to get some stuff from A to B
I'm willing to take that and sacrifice
and do it if there's some sort of train
that must go up through Canada to Alaska
I don't know I'm not well versed and
trained neither am I I'm just asking I
would at least look into it there's got
to be something where I could throw my
stuff on there I'd go hey who's heading
that way and got a trailer I'll throw my
stuff in there I'll pay the guy a
thousand bucks to haul it that's what
I'm saying I'm just saying I get
creative I don't know without a Facebook
post see what people say it's got to be
a train
we're out here dispouting some ideas but
we want to help you win with your work
life your money life so give us a call
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five keep us company won't you we'll be
right back
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
oh
welcome back to the Ramsey Show
our team has been doing some research on
Mental Health in the workplace and uh
it's not looking great guys employees
say in the last month they've felt
stressed burnt out overwhelmed and even
angry at work so if you're a business or
HR leader you may be seeing this
firsthand your employees are distracted
they're exhausted and maybe even ready
to quit so here's the deal guys good
leaders take their employees well-being
seriously because it's good for both
your employees and your business when
they're well and they can bring their
full selves to work and you can help
them do that this month is employee
well-being month and there's no better
time to make your employees mental
health a priority so our team over at
smart dollar has put together a ton of
free Mental Health Resources for leaders
like you who don't want to sit on the
sidelines of their employees well-being
any longer
you can dig into the research get
information on how to deal with mental
health in the workplace and find tools
to help your team get well so that they
can focus on their work you and your
employees are worth being well as our
friend Dr John deloney would say so go
to ramseysolutions.com employee
well-being to check out those free
resources again that's
ramseysolutions.com
employee well-being all one word good
stuff all right I'm George Campbell
joined by Ken Coleman we're getting to
the phones now a number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Dorothy is in DC hey Dorothy
hi George and Ken I'm calling in today
because I'm working on baby steps four
and six simultaneously and I wanted to
know whether or not I should buy a new
car with the extended warranty for about
fifty four thousand dollars whoa
okay this is a party what do you make
Dorothy
um I currently make
um about uh 70 or 80 000 a year why did
you laugh
because I wrote that information down
but I don't have it in front of me right
now oh okay okay so what's the deal with
this new car
during a car accident back in April I
got a settlement for it for about eight
thousand dollars and then I plan to put
ten thousand out ten thousand down on
the new car
um adding the tax refund that I'm
expecting to get of about two thousand
dollars so how much money do you have in
the bank
I have about seventy seven thousand
dollars seventy seven thousand
yes sir whoa what is that from
that is from me saving for my emergency
fund so if I take out the 36 from the
emergency fund it leaves 41 000 the rest
of the money is for me Airbnb in my
primary home while I'm away on Military
orders okay so you've got an Airbnb
you've got your emergency fund in there
and that's that's money that's set aside
for those things but for the car you
don't have money to buy this car right
now
I don't have the full amount of money to
buy the car but I also didn't want to
empty my bank account completely when
I'm trying to build more with the new
LLC I just started for real estate
investment here's what I'm saying
Dorothy you are so smart in fact you are
too smart to go into car loan debt for a
car that you can't afford that's over
half your income
so weird I'm confused where this is
coming from you have no debt right now
right
no I don't but I didn't want to prevent
myself from building additional wealth
through the new business that I just
started but can I tell you that buying a
car is the number one way to kill your
wealth
to go into debt with interest on a
depreciating asset
okay so the question is how much money
do we have and then we go all right how
much car can we get for that amount of
money that's how I would be looking at
this thing
so the problem is when I was comparing
new cars to used cars
um they were just about not that much
not that much cheaper for one and two I
need a reliable car in order to get back
and forth to work okay so let's look at
the real numbers so I thought I heard
you say tell me if I'm wrong that you
had uh eight thousand dollars from the
settlement and you you had 10 that you
were going to put did I hear eighteen
thousand is how I got there is that what
I heard no you heard eight plus two from
the tax refund so that is how I get to
the 10. oh you have ten to put towards
okay good that's why I asked okay so
um you think that you can't have a
reliable car that you would purchase for
ten thousand dollars is that fair
yes all right so what is the number that
makes it reliable in your mind
how much more well because you're not
looking for when I was looking at other
Honda Accords to replace the one that
was totaled it was about thirty thousand
dollars for one year for what year of a
Honda Accord
uh 2019. exactly I'm sitting next to a
Honda Accord specialist in George
Campbell who drove I drove a Civic I
apologize a Civic but a Honda Civic but
one of my dream cars Dorothy was a Honda
Accord all right but my point is is that
if she's looking at a 2010 2011 2012. uh
all of a sudden Dorothy the price of
those Hondas that will run forever if
you take care of them and you have
enough money to be able to take care of
basic repairs that's why we have that
emergency fund I'm I just you you've
gotten your mind that the only thing
that's reliable is 30 to 54 000 and
that's just simply not the case
so imagine then if I'm right and you may
not think I am but imagine if I am now
you have zero dollars in car payment
versus whatever your car payment is
going to be with that fifty four
thousand dollar car
it would potentially be 660 a month okay
4.9 for 72. that's crazy that hurts my
heart to see Dorothy's income get sent
to
Honda lender because she wanted a nice
car
it would be Volkswagen this time but yes
I understand your point okay but it's
over eight thousand dollars of a pay cut
for you if you buy this car
yes okay then that's what we're trying
to plead with you on
we're not anti-people buying cars just
for the sake of buying a car it's that
it doesn't make Financial sense for you
and please do not get the extended
warranty those are a giant rip-off and
the mathematics behind it shows that
they are almost never worth it and so if
you want peace of mind you have an
emergency fund for that and so if there
is a repair you're going to be able to
cover it and if you get a reliable
vehicle like the Honda Accord for
example and you get a pre-purchase
inspection on it you can find a very
reasonable used Honda and while Honda
and Toyota they're going to hold their
value pretty well because they're great
cars everyone knows that and so you may
pay you know 10 grand for a I don't know
a 2010 Accord and you might go all right
that's reasonable I had an 09 Civic I
paid six grand for it that thing will
probably Outlast me if I'm gonna be
honest I will it'll probably for me with
buying a 2010 Honda Accord is that that
literally was the car that I had and it
only had 129 uh 129 000 miles on it and
now it's gone
because of a car wreck so the 54 000 car
has got the same chance of getting
totaled as well
there's no difference the only owner of
the car so me doing the comparison of
what the other people did or didn't do
as far as maintenance keeps Milling
around in my head well they have reports
that show you exactly what maintenance
was done and if you get the right car
from the right place they're going to
have all of that for you and they'll
show you exactly when the oil changes
were done when the brakes were replaced
and all of that stuff
and I'm telling you with a pre-purchase
inspection it takes all the worry out
they're going to go look at the thing
and go hey here's the issues here's what
it doesn't have and here's what it would
cost to fix up or it's in great
condition go buy the car and that'll
cost you 100 to 150 bucks to get that
done at your local mechanic Dorothy we
get calls all the time on the show from
people who bought a car same price same
range and then something goes wrong in
their world their business or whatever
and all of a sudden they realize they're
upside down this car because your car is
going to depreciate and a year from now
you could be upside down in this car
and then you're really in trouble
okay so you see the difference between
paying cash for something versus you you
finance it and then it is depreciating
on you and then you then you're stuck
you're not stuck right now I hate that
your car got totaled but you got an
eight thousand dollar check for it and
you can put some cash on top of what you
got and you can get a reliable car
you're trying to make a business go
you're trying to go all in last thing an
entrepreneur needs is a car payment it's
just going to be weighing you down
as you get this LLC off the ground and
we want to see you in that's it I want
Dorothy to be driving like no one else
but right now we got to drive like no
one else you know what I mean
okay so I guess my my follow-up question
and final idea is that I'm basically
looking at the comparison of using other
people's money or money or getting into
debt for the business versus getting
into debt for the car and what I'm
hearing you say is getting into the debt
for the car isn't worth it because of
the depreciation getting into debt for
anything isn't worth it and if you're
going to use it for the business for
sure not I want you to run your business
debt free and we show you how to do that
in the book entree leadership and I'm
going to send it to you to give you some
Hope on the business side and on the car
side go to AutoTrader or true cars and
start looking and sort by your actual
budget which right now is ten thousand
dollars and get what you can afford
right now and you can always upgrade
down the line down the line until you're
driving like no one else so hang on the
line we'll send you a Dave's
best-selling book entree leadership to
show you that it's possible to run a
business completely debt free thanks for
the call
[Music]
thank you
I'm George Campbell joined by Ken
Coleman this hour this is the Ramsay
show
now Ken there was some big news on
Twitter a viral thread a few good news
big news I saw this and it was all about
the crash of Airbnb right not the
company itself the company itself is
actually doing well it's for all the
people that own the airbnbs right and
would this be would it be safe to say
this this is also a VRBO or verbo or
whatever they call it all the short-term
rental okay situations out there
so this is uh from Nick jurly who's CEO
of reventure Consulting he's apparently
got the number one Real Estate Channel
on YouTube that's according to his
Twitter bio okay has not been verified
okay but he said the Airbnb collapse is
real revenues are down nearly 50 percent
in cities like Phoenix and Austin and he
said watch out for a wave of force
selling from Airbnb owners later this
year in the area's hit hardest in the
revenue collapse
yeah so this is wild stuff if you're
watching our viewing audience can see
they're on the screen uh he gives the
top 10 cities uh and look at that we've
got two uh in uh the uh two in the top
ten in Tennessee
Sevierville which is just outside of
Pigeon Forge or right around Pigeon
Forge Smoky Mountains area uh number one
on the list and then look at that number
eight Nashville Tennessee so this is uh
this is very relevant across the country
but certainly in our state and what has
happened George is everybody started
watching those tick tocks those
Instagrams all these real estate gurus
yeah in there get the no money down
start Building Wealth now baby look at
me on my private jet look at me do what
I did and now uh oh we have more Supply
than demand yes basic economics that
nobody ever talks about on Tick Tock and
Instagram yeah they're way more airbnbs
available so as the supply goes up but
there is actually decreasing demand for
those yeah and here's the other kicker
there's way more airbnbs than there are
actually homes for sale so this could
lead to a lot of for selling and for
people that did the no Down plan or did
almost nothing down for these rental
properties without the revenue coming in
they could be screwed where they have to
be a for sale foreclosures they're going
to default on these loans
and that could be a real scary situation
crazy man I um
now does this mean that uh for those of
us that want to vacation this year we
should be uh looking for some good rates
I would hope so I would think that's the
case as Airbnb gets spooked they may try
to raise the rates so that the people
that still are participating pay more
and therefore offset those that aren't
doing it which is always a risky move
that feels really risky I agree but
their revenue uh you know per booking is
up which tells me they're raising their
prices and people that are still willing
to pay are doing it okay that was my
question so we are seeing in the numbers
that revenue is up yeah okay airbnb's
revenues up so the company itself right
is doing great but rates are up the
folks that are keeping their company
alive you know the the mom and pops out
there who went hey let's get an Airbnb
it'll be great a little extra vacation
Revenue coming in would be awesome this
is going to be part of our retirement
plan and now they're going we can't
cover the mortgage because here's the
kicker Ken everyone goes well the Airbnb
is going to cover the mortgage plus some
so this is a no-brainer why wouldn't I
do this move well you forgot to include
risk and things like this happen yeah
and you go oh it wasn't just a
money-making scene I forgot about that
and so this could be a real dangerous
situation and they're saying that as the
reality sets in that Gap could close in
a way that decreases home prices and
Shirley believes that more seasoned
Airbnb operators who got in before the
pandemic might be able to hang on but
those newbie owners who paid more for
their properties at higher interest
rates those folks could be in trouble
because they've got thin margins that
could leave lead to that way before
selling yikes so one more reminder and
this is our our stance on investment
properties which are toys by the way
those are just luxury is don't do it
unless you can pay cash for it and if
you're going oh my gosh that's insane
you know what's insane putting nothing
down and then putting yourself in a
financial situation where you have to
force sell in the house because you
can't afford the mortgage and it's going
to lead to a lot of people getting
financially hurt that stepped into this
thing the wrong way the people with paid
for airbnbs they're not that worried
it's an inconvenience instead of a cry
cases for those folks because they're in
a much better financial position because
they're not desperate to have that
occupancy in Revenue coming in
yeah this is uh boy you play with fire
you get burned and this is an example of
this this is going to be very
interesting to see uh what happens here
because a lot of experts I'm not trying
to get off topic it's actually not off
topic but a lot of experts are
predicting that we're going to see a
surge in home foreclosures as well uh
you know because we've seen a lot of you
know things be installed and now we're
back into it well and with with student
loan News student loans people are going
oh I guess I will have to factor in that
student loan payment and guess what you
can't bankrupt on your student loans and
so what's going to happen is people go I
bought too much house during the
pandemic while student loan pause was
happening and all of a sudden we have to
have this extra expense of four or five
600 700 in student loan payments we
can't afford it well you can't get rid
of the student loan payments no and so
you may have to force sell your home or
default on the mortgage and foreclosure
closures could happen all across the
nation this is a bad situation so please
budget for it make a plan look at the
numbers and don't step into real estate
because somebody on Tick Tock said
here's the plan buy my course do the
nothing down I can get you the right
mortgage the best plan is the a 100 Down
plan where you pay cash for that toy and
it becomes a blessing instead of a
burden in your life you know do your
research on some of those Folks by the
way just a little thing here if they're
making more money on their courses than
they are on the actual strategies that
they're selling you you might want to
walk away yep yep and these people are
also I like to rag on them because they
love to rag on us they'll go oh they're
good Dave Ramsey doesn't know what he's
talking about man this is really the
secret wealth hacks that you need to
know about and I just block them so
there you go that's one way to do it oh
I'm proud of you thank you yeah because
you kind of done with the trolls I'm
getting to that age because you used to
engage with the trolls and wallow in the
comments and I'm glad to see that you're
uh I still do it occasionally I know
just to feel something yeah
self-loathing yes
oh I can't do it I I can't engage in it
it doesn't do anything good for me at
all that's fair it's like a blood
pressure I need some mental health
advice from Dr John deloney yeah let's
take a quick call here from Nick in
Grand Rapids Nick welcome to the show
hey can you hear me yeah how you doing
good how are you guys great
so I got a question here I uh I bought
my house uh just over a year ago
um and I before that I was renting with
a group of friends and then um our lease
uh was running out so I didn't know
where to go because rent was pretty
expensive around here so I ended up just
looking for a house because of the uh
low mortgage rates and
um the house I currently live in is
um I'd say it's pretty expensive to live
in because of uh it's an older house and
I
um have a lot of upkeep with getting a
new
um furnace and water heater and uh it
has a pool as well that I have to upkeep
so I'm just curious to see if you think
I should keep staying here and living
here and or just sell the house and try
to either buy a new one next year or
even just uh rent somewhere what is your
take-home pay
um
about thirty two hundred dollars a month
and what's the mortgage including the
taxes Insurance all that
1600.
yeah that's fifty percent of your
take-home pay and that's not even
including all the maintenance and
repairs
yeah how big is the house
uh 1600 square feet could you get some
some more roommates
uh yes I currently live with uh two
other roommates okay and so your
mortgage is 1600 what are they paying
um 700. okay so you only have to put out
200 bucks
that's correct so what's killing you
about this situation right now
financially that you have to sell it
um I think there's just the toll has
taken on more of my personal life
um and more of uh doing uh kind of house
chores and maintenance on the house that
I have to keep repairing things or have
to uh like I said the pool ends up
taking up a couple hours a day after
work and so uh I just I wasn't sure if I
should just keep doing this or if I
should get out and kind of rebuild my
personal life again
I mean if it's for your personal life
I'm I'll hire a pool guy and go how do
we factor that into the budget but I
don't think selling this thing is going
to solve all your problems if it's a
nuisance long term I would go ahead and
sell it long term just because you're
not ready to be a homeowner if you're
not willing to take all that on but the
200 bucks you're paying is not what's
killing you it's the time that you're
putting into it and see if the roommates
can ship in maybe reduce their rent if
they help you around doing some of these
repairs that could be an option
tough situation man this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show our
scripture of the day comes from Proverbs
12 22 the Lord detest lying lips but he
Delights in people who are trustworthy
Thomas Jefferson said honesty is the
first chapter in the book of wisdom love
a good TJ quote man I love these quotes
in light of the uh the student loan news
today Ken when we found out these
politicians have been lying to us for a
long time now well but we tried I know
that every time I was on this show that
I had the opportunity I said do not
count on this this is an empty political
promise that is not legal and the
Supreme Court upheld this decision today
now what stinks about that is is a lot
of people believe that and for those of
you that this is a real shot to the gut
today I'm sorry yeah they got do
um we are not happy that you didn't get
this relief we told you you weren't
going to but here's the good news you
are your own student debt relief and we
can walk this journey with you we've
done it for a lot of people so you can
do it I did it I paid off my student
loans well a lot of people their lives
on hold and that upsets me because
there's so much progress they could have
been making I agree but instead they
were waiting with baited breath with a
carrot dangling in front of them from
politicians and we know that never ends
well so I want you guys to know that
we're here for you we want to help you
make a plan to pay off these student
loans you can call the Ramsey Show check
out our resources we want to help you in
that way taking that next step
well as you guys enjoy uh you know
Independence Day and the holiday you can
also sign up for our free newsletter at
ramseysolutions.com
newsletter and I this is a fun one are
you gonna have to start calling your
baby steps teenage steps before you pay
off debt speed up the journey with a
side hustle 25 solid ways to make extra
cash so you can get on your way to
knocking out your goals maybe one of
those goals is paying off student loan
debt what are you doing for uh the
fourth buddy we are headed to the beach
ah yeah very nice down on the Panhandle
in Florida the last trip to the beach
before baby that's true I know yeah that
makes very exciting that kind of puts it
into perspective are you gonna grill out
I hope so do you eat hot dogs you're
clean yeah yeah I mean you'll have a
Frank yeah I want a high quality Frank
if I'm going to be honest if I'm gonna
be frank with you
there it is folks there it is I uh I
don't eat hot dogs is that a hard
personal stance you take care no I just
over the years I've faded away from them
not against them at all wouldn't guilt
anybody at all I'll be making some at my
place but uh I go with the uh smoked
chicken wings oh and uh a good burger
you know all right maybe some homemade
pizzas on the kamado Joe I might skip
the vacation and go to the Coleman's
there you go you guys are living the
dream it's gonna be fun I love it we'll
have a safe and happy uh fourth everyone
happy fourth to everybody and make sure
to check out that newsletter
ramseysolutions.com
newsletter let's go to Leslie and San
Antonio Leslie welcome to the show
hi George hi Ken uh I just had a quick
question
um my vehicle was totaled last month and
I got a payout settlement for it and I
don't want to spend the full amount and
my husband would feel more comfortable
going to like a dealership situation
which is how we bought our previous
vehicle and I'm potentially like open to
finding something on a Facebook
Marketplace or private party sale but we
don't have a lot of experience in that
and feel a little hesitant and I know
Ken you've mentioned that you I do
you've done a lot of research with that
I'm your resident Facebook Marketplace
vehicle purchasing expert uh that's who
yeah I'm here for you so how much money
did you get for the settlement
uh we got twelve thousand dollars which
is what we paid for the vehicle five
years ago oh well that's great news uh
yeah so you said you didn't want to use
all of that what are you thinking what's
the amount you want to spend I would
feel nine or ten would be great great
okay so Facebook Marketplace all right
so couple of quick tips and George I'm
sure you've got some as well sure but uh
I I from my experience
um you need to check out the rating or
the quality of the seller if they've
sold multiple things that have a good
rating that's a good sign but that's not
enough
um and then you check out the car you
communicate with them ahead of time the
more they communicate the more open they
are that's a good sign let's go look at
the car and then after we've looked at
it I would ask them if they'd be willing
to let you take it to your mechanic and
and and that's my checklist if any of
those don't check out I check out
there it is it's that simple because
look you got to protect yourself
um but if you get your mechanic to check
it out and they're willing to do that
that means they're not trying to take
you for a ride and then you then you get
your mechanic to tell you everything
that's wrong with it tear it apart and
now you're dealing with reality and
facts and you're not nothing to be
scared of at that point yeah that's a
good call and I'll tell you would you
recommend oh sorry no continue George no
go ahead well I am I'm like there's the
sticker price that's how much you're
asking me to pay I'm gonna pay that but
I how do I go about negotiating that
when I'm very much like you said it cost
ten thousand okay I guess that's what
I'm paying oh yeah this is oh I should
have given you this tip this is so fun
so uh do your research on the Kelley
Blue Book so match it up and see if
they're in the high range medium range
or low range and then walk in there and
just say I'm a cash buyer and so if
they're asking 10 and let's say that
it's on the high end I absolutely am
going to offer and unless that the
medium range for that vehicle is 8 500.
I'm offering eight
that's just where I'm going I'm going to
go below the mid-range on that and see
if I can get them to come down you know
we meet in the middle but uh you know I
I've never bought a car cash George
where I couldn't get the person down
you know I don't make a ridiculous he
drives a hard bargain no I just make a
fair offer based on the Range but I say
that I go look the range is this you're
on the high side I feel good offering
you eight
and they go would you do 9100 and you go
ah
I think the most I'd feel good about
here is 8400 you know and it's just this
whole back and forth and if the price is
fair you can just pay the price or the
or you can do that too if the price is
fair give them what they ask for so it
depends on your comfortability with
confrontation to be honest with you
because you don't have to be ugly about
it but most people feel like negotiation
is confrontation and it's not my wife
will just be like I'm gonna go in the
car while you do this it's very
uncomfortable for me so she does that
I'm The Negotiator guy I'm playing hard
I smile the whole time I look them right
in the eye never lose eye contact and if
you get the feel like they're kind of
scummy just leave and go somewhere else
don't play that game there's a lot of
reputable independent used car
dealerships out there if you want to go
that route it sounds like your husband
is wanting to go to like the new
dealership which they do sell used cars
there and you can find a deal we bought
my wife's car from a Mazda dealership
and they had a great used car that was
like seven or eight grand and so we went
great we'll just do it it was a very
quick easy transaction the other option
is of course private sellers like Ken
mentioned and the other one is these
online car retailers now you're gonna
have a tough time finding something in
that price range because the deal with
those is hey no haggle it's easy we've
already inspected it we've got all the
reports but you kind of pay what you see
on the web that's correct there is no
negotiation so it just depends on your
comfortability your budget and start
looking go to truecars and auto trader
and Facebook Marketplace and get a feel
for what kind of car you're able to
afford always get that pre-purchase
inspection it'll be about 150 bucks and
then lastly on negotiating agree on an
out the door price that means hey after
all the fees and taxes which by the way
I'm not paying any fees Beyond a real
tiny doc fee
it's going to be the price of the car
the sales tax and a small dock fee
anything other than that I'm going I'm
not paying it if they want to throw on
these warranties and then we did the
reconditioning fee don't let them do
that who needs a shout George all right
stay calm here uh we have a great car
buying guide as well Leslie I'll make
sure the team sends it to you it's good
and we will link it in the show notes
and it's a fantastic guide that goes
through all of these steps because I
know we're throwing a lot at you
by the way if you're in Tennessee and
you're listening to the show right now
my wife Stacy Coleman we just listed a
car we're selling uh Hey selling one of
our cars just uh you know so just put
that out there hey you can say well
Thomas RX 330 you know that's a great
car run forever I think we're looking
more towards the minivan side I know I
actually wasn't trying to sell you that
car I was just saying in Tennessee
you're too far away it would be some
legendary radio if we were able to sell
Ken's car my wife would be so thrilled
I'd come home Patty she goes how was
your day I sold the car
on the air no I love that Leslie's going
here's our budget here's what we can
afford I like we're gonna find something
for nine or ten Grand and if we need to
negotiate to do that or willing to do it
now I'm not going to say don't buy from
a dealer okay or an independent dealer
but I will tell you my experience I'd
much rather buy from a real person
they're not marking it up and I and I
usually trust them a little bit more I'm
just gonna throw that out there that's
fair well hey thank you to everyone that
listens to the show that's subscribed
reviewed shared with a friend we were
rated best podcast of the year and we
were the most requested on Alexa that's
pretty cool my mom
Amazon music and podcasts we got that
data in thank you so much for listening
to the show until next time America
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
foreign
[Music]
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsaysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsaysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]